[Musique]
cette semaine on revisite notre enquête
sur la contrebande d'alcool au nunavik
avec de nouveaux développements c'est un
reportage qui vous avait beaucoup ému
l'hiver dernier je me mettais un peu mes
parent quantis patey mes grands parents
boivent aussi des fois j'ai cette
cuisine est tout seul
[Musique]
les enfants sont négligés les enfants au
sein parce que l'alcool est vendu
illégalement elles vraiment cher si
l'alcool coule à flots au nunavik c'est
beaucoup grâce aux contrebandiers
véritable bouclé que des temps modernes
notre enquête en rediffusion mais aussi
sur la sellette la société des alcools
du québec qui a longtemps fermé les yeux
sur le phénomène
c'est sûr qu'ils savent c'est sociaux
ils ont été sensibilisés eu des
rencontres dans le passé avec eux
doivent poser la question pourquoi tu
l'as kursaal de dorval autant de ventes
de bouteilles de ce mr nord
on est retourné à la saq en caméra
cachée pour voir si les choses ont
changé ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
m
et j'estime obama in tournon par nature
l'honneur grâce au mouvement
bon là à motonat ça veut dire rien
qu'une femme juste une femme tout une
femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
novatrice
ça va mais oui oui tout une femme pour
dénoncer publiquement l'un des pires
maux qui rongent de nunavik la
contrebande d'alcool ce marché noir
rapporte gros aux trafics à des dizaines
de millions par année des bouteilles de
vodka achetée à la saq 14 dollars et
revendus illégalement dans le grand nord
550 $ et parfois plus en vues teaser je
suis pas sûr que ça
la revente d'alcool existe au vu et au
su de la saq
les inuits vient du nord en acheter pour
leur vendre là bas puis leur vente soit
entre 5 et 10 fois le prix dans l'alcool
de contrebande débarque dans les
communautés la violence éclate dès que
ça rentre
on reçoit des appels c'est pas des
problèmes mineurs non plus des gens
meurent des enfants perdent leur
innocence
les enfants sont violés les aimer son
volant
ça ça tue l'esprit d'une personne
il n'y a pas de valeur
[Musique]
la chanteuse béatrice dire interprète ce
champ inuit en compagnie d'enfants de
coke tac son village natal mais derrière
ses sourires innocents se cache souvent
de grandes souffrances
c'est d'abord pour les enfants du
nunavik que béatrice d'hier a décidé de
sonner l'alarmé et de diffuser ce
message sur facebook qui s'en prend aux
buttes ligue 1 ces trafiquants d'alcool
tout en haut
après l'oréal les problèmes d'alcool au
nunavik sont connus ils sont la
conséquence des nombreux traumatismes
subis par les inuits la colonisation des
pensionnats l'abattage des chiens de
traîneaux la consommation excessive
d'alcool
et c'est important de le mentionner ne
touche pas la majorité des inuits
mais les dérives d'une minorité sont
assez graves pour que la plupart des
villages interdisent la vente d'alcool
sur leur territoire il permet toutefois
l'achat en ligne d'une quantité limitée
de bière de vin et de spiritueux
les contrebandiers eux sont ouverts jour
et nuit
t'as quoi
eminem not hate au pinacle aura mené il
noir n'est pas condamnée et mai à lomé a
cru télé son message a été partagé plus
de 700 fois et a suscité beaucoup de
commentaires tous positifs
il faut beaucoup de sagesse pour avoir
le courage de dire la vérité toute crue
comme tu fais merci d'aborder ce sujet
délicat
on a besoin de plus de gens comme toi un
sujet grave
triste effrayant frustrant
nous avons rencontré béatrice dira
quoique tac ce petit village de 450
personnes situées du côté de la baie
d'ungava bien triste nous amène au
cimetière en haut de la colline lui et
susciter aussi que l'âge des jeunes
joueurs et comme 22 à 21
celui-ci bruit à cause de colt oui ça
c'est une option de suite sur ceux des
mères il voulait pas d'un projet
d'accord 16 ans pendant 14 ans
toute sa vie toute sa vie
visiblement bois ouais bah t'es de cloud
et saas est c'est vraiment un mort dans
le ventre de sa mère pendant le père
abattu sa mère était ce sont des gens
qui sont supposés être des vingt grands
sont pas supposés enterrés ici
parmi toutes ces croix blanche une toute
récente celle de janis 10e sa nièce qui
s'est suicidé elle venait tout juste
d'avoir 18 ans elle avait des problèmes
d'alcool
ouais est ce qu'elle voyait les boucles
à gaz ouais sur m'a sûrement est
libérées tout le temps
les bootleggers n'hésitent pas à vendre
à des mineurs fin janvier 2019 un
blizzard souffle sur le village de salou
est tout au nord du québec
maggie tayara à 15 ans elle passe la
soirée une partie de la nuit à boire
avec des amis
le lendemain matin son corps
complètement je les ai retrouvés sous
une maison
le rapport du coroner confirme une
hypothermie et une intoxication à
l'alcool et au cannabis
la vodka qui a contribué à tuer magee
avait été acheté chez un bootlegger au
nunavik près de 75% des actes criminels
sont commis sous l'influencé de l'alcool
les bootleggers on parmi leur clientèle
ceux à qui le tribunal interdit de
consommer on en avait il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas supposés avoir de l'accès à
l'alcool comme des préfets par exemple
qu'elles vont boire il ya des arbres
partout
le format de 375 mille litres de vodka
qu'on appelle un ami qui est le plus
populaire il se vend 100 dollars soit 7
fois le prix régulier ce qui est loin
d'arrêter les gros buveurs
c'est beaucoup d'argent qui s'envolent
rapidement
alicia lara gut ac en sait quelque chose
elle a vécu avec une mère qui flambait
son argent chez les revendeurs d'alcool
[Musique]
elle s'en tenir à un nom propre aux
propos manqueront à l'adolescence alicia
va faire exactement comme sa mère
[Musique]
frisco faucheurs
tél
alicia s'en est sorti et elle est
déterminée à offrir à sa fille une plus
belle enfance mais encore aujourd'hui
pour plusieurs enfants au nunavik la
situation se répète
les enfants sont négligés les enfants
enfin parce que l'alcool qui est vendu
illégalement est vraiment chère ses
petites-filles mange avec appétit si le
repas que leur prix paris béatrice elles
sont venus voir leurs idoles de passage
à quoique tac
ces enfants sont régulièrement privés de
nourriture
c'est à béatrice qualifiait ton confie
ce qu'elles vivent à la maison vous ne
verrez pas leurs visages ils nous avons
changé leurs voix afin de protéger leur
identité par hacquard lectorat che sur
mes grands parents boivent aussi des
fois j'ai cette cuisine est tout seul
menés par aso
je peux maintenant faire du riz l'alcool
c'est aussi toute la violence familiale
qu'il engendre je me mettais un de mes
parents quand il se battait comme
gestion très forte des tirs amis parents
d'arrêter bord un an plus tard ils sont
retombés temps alors commencé à boire
mes parents ont dit qu elle est arrêtée
mais ils ont continué et tout le
désarroi des fois je suis pas bien
traité je me suis fait dire que j'ai
voulu me suicider le mener à oman air et
minéraux match que je me suis fait taire
une manière maracana déclaré allant
voter
de la musique un peu de réconfort de
légèreté pour ses enfants avant qu'elle
ne retourne chez elle dans la nuit
[Musique]
la population du nunavik ont près de
14000 personnes sur les 14 villages
trois seulement peut vendre de l'alcool
coup de joie qu elle ainsi village il y
a deux bars et le magasin coop permet à
certaines heures la vente de bière et de
vin
la décision de vendre de l'alcool n'a
pas eu d'impact sur le marché noir bien
au contraire
la situation s'est même aggravée quand
beaucoup trop attendre de plusieurs
façons sa lampe au départ déjà qui
voyagent par 4 go par la poste par
bateau l'été dont il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de points a adressé ce qui fait
en sorte que c'est très difficile pour
nous de contrer
tout l'alcool illégal qui rentrent au
mna vécu
dénoncer la contrebande c'est une chose
dénoncer contrebandiers c'est plus
risqué
pas évident non plus quand le
contrebandier fait partie de la famille
c'est difficile parce que comme tu vois
essayé on est dans la colonne puis on
voit presque tout le village
comment quand même moment que le monde
une façon à l'eau je suis parent avec un
tiers de ce village
de retour à coups de joie qu deux jeunes
femmes dont nous tairons l'identité pour
des raisons de sécurité nous montre avec
quelle facilité on peut trouver de
l'alcool illégal une première vendeuse
contacter sur messenger répond dans la
minute
le soir oui entre
petit trouver une autre place j'en ai
déjà trouvé elle se rend à cette
deuxième adresse
qu'est-ce que vous fais ton cher jamie
king jarlet après une minute
justin et
[Musique]
un but isis je suis passé jusqu'à ce que
la contrebande se fait à petite et
grande échelle la police actuellement
dans sa mire un bootlegger de montréal
dont les revenus sont dans les sept
chiffres
on connait un on a tous au dessus
il a fait 4 millions $ il a dépensé je
pense 60000 effet 4 mio
en parcourant facebook nous trouvons ce
trafiquant des bouteilles de vodka sont
bien en évidence sur sa page d'accueil
et des billets de banques servent de
photos de profil nous demandons un
collaborateur de le contacter en se
faisant passer pour un client qui veut
acheter de l'alcool l'homme qui dit être
à montréal lui donne des directives bien
précises
le conte tous fait la transaction en
question se trouve au cameroun
photos à l'appui il dit envoyait
régulièrement de l'alcool est aussi du
cannabis par postes canada et air inuit
et nous propose allez voir le site de sa
compagnie qui vend du cannabis à des
fins médicales mais aussi de la cocaïne
de l'ecstasy et du crystal meth
nous l'avons rappelé pour lui demander
de nous accorder une entrevue il a bien
sûr refusé
il nous a fait parvenir ce message bien
senties payan s'adresser à des policiers
d'autres trafiquants recrue des
intermédiaires souvent des inuit pour
faire les achats d'alcool
à montréal ils se rendent surtout ici à
la saq de dorval près de l'aéroport
trudeau où atterrissent les vols en
provenance du nunavik d'ailleurs les
bouteilles de vodka sont bien en
évidence
à l'entrée du magasin l'information à
l'effet que landreau il y avait le plus
de bouteille de la saq n'a jamais voulu
corroborer cette affirmation le monopole
d'état nous a écrit que la divulgation
de ces renseignements risquerait de
porter atteinte à ses intérêts
économiques
[Musique]
tous les employés à qui nous avons parlé
dans cette succursale nous ont confirmé
la très grande popularité de la vodka et
la revente de cet alcool ou nunavik
ah ça sans madame comment ça ça sort
tout seul comme un seuil en tout sauf
personnellement oui oui ce qu'on voit
ici c'est beaucoup pour la revente ya
j'attends à 15 passes qui font tellement
d'argent un vendeur s'est connus ceux
qui font ça et en plus ma valise devant
vous au oui il y en a toutes les deux
trois jours il vient chercher dickens
pour la pub en ligne ou non un blanc un
blanc à chaque de trois jours je pense
que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille là bas
toujours dans cette même succursale un
homme d'origine inuit remplit son
chariot de bouteilles de vodka
ce qu'il fait est tout à fait légale
mais une fois à l'extérieur de la saq
son comportement est plutôt curieux ils
transfèrent les bouteilles d'alcool dans
un sac et y ajoute des paquets de
bonbons les aliments secs peuvent
masquer des sons compromettants
comme nous le confirme l'enquêteur qui
n'est pas un ami
les grains qu'elle fait ça sent bon et
ça fait du bruit il pense qu'on ne va
pas s'apercevoir qu'il y à de l'alcool
parce que ça couvre bien le son du
liquide
il traverse au bureau de poste et
envoient leurs colis c'est exactement ce
que fait cet homme il transfère
maintenant les bouteilles et les bonbons
dans une boîte de postes canada alors
qu'il est illégal d'envoyer de l'alcool
par la poste
le colis est ensuite déposée au comptoir
il est destiné au nunavik l'employé n'a
rien remarqué
[Musique]
nous voulons à notre tour vérifier c'est
aussi facile qu'on a dit d'envoyer de
l'alcool dans le grand nord puisque
c'est illégal nous remplissons nos
bouteilles d'eau du robinet pour éviter
tout bruit de liquide
nous ajoutons des pâtes alimentaires si
c'était 35 bouteille de vodka
le prix régulier serait de 500 $ cette
même quantité pourrait être revendu en
quelques heures au nunavik 3500 $ un
profit intéressante
nous enverrons nos deux boîtes par les
compagnies first air et air inuit et la
troisième par la poste
destination coup jack et kwata verrons
si elles seront interceptés devancé
entrée massive d'alcool
on peut dire que les deux seuls
enquêteurs du nunavik en ont plein les
bras on a saisi de l'alcool de
contrebande partout nunavik ça ça vient
de saint louis est principalement de sa
lutte mais aussi new jack et beaucoup de
coups du wac
la police compte beaucoup sur les appels
anonymes du public pour les aider à
détecter les colis suspect en 2019
le montant des saisies s'est élevé à
près de 800 24 mille dollars
c'est presque le double de l'année
précédente on n'aura plus ce n'est qu'un
aperçu de ce qui se passe là plus
importantes saisies d'alcool au nunavik
a eu lieu en 2018 dans une résidence de
coups de joie qu la sûreté du québec a
collaboré avec la police régionale
kativik
mais tu johnson était l'enquêteur
principal on a trouvé 29 mai le dollar
en argent comptant et je dirais 250
micky de votre corps ou de rome et 30
caisses de bière sur le marché noir ça
vaut 35 mille dollars
[Musique]
les trafiquants d'alcool est retombé
anne et son fils samy selon la police
vendait aussi à des mineurs ils ont
écopé de l'amendé maximale à cause de la
quantité d'alcool et d'argent saisis
soit une amende d'environ 4000 chacun
s'est pas beaucoup pour tout l'argent
qu'ils forment
je suis bien d'accord avec vous et des
peines qui ne sont pas très dissuasive
nous avons retrouvé rtnb le
contrebandier en question il travaille
dans une épicerie à coude jacques
[Musique]
une alcool beaucoup plus puissant que la
vodka circulent au nunavik de l'alcool à
94%
ces sacs en contiennent chacun 4 litres
l'envoi était destiné aux petits
villages d'ateliers où vivent environ
600 personnes
un flasque de 375 millilitres à 26
dollars se vend sur le marché noir
300 dollars nathalie bélanger a
travaillé comme infirmière au
dispensaire d'accous livic sur la côte
de l'hudson elle a traité très souvent
des patients fortement intoxiqué au 94 %
les codes hémorragie digestive ou les
gens ont saigné un alcool qui se
retrouvent bien souvent entre les mains
d'adolescents
je vais surtout les jeunes et les femmes
ont consommé du 94 sur son retrouver une
aussi soir est conscient que ce soit un
match qui clôt 167 verizon sont obligés
de toutes les façons 1
[Applaudissements]
après la pause des policiers
complètement dépassés par l'ampleur de
la contrebande et on découvre le rôle de
postes canada des compagnies aériennes
et de la saq
[Musique]
je comprends pas comment de sa queue qui
est une branche du gouvernement du
québec fait pas de recherche est ce
qu'ils sont vraiment vraiment pas
capable de voir qu'il ya des gens qui
vivent illégalement de l'alcool qui
vient de nous on a beaucoup de gens
disent malheureuse qui achètent des
grosses caisses puis qui amène seul à
bord
les employés le savent mais qu'en est il
de la direction nous avons voulu poser
la question la présidente de la saq
catherine dagenais notre demande
d'entrevue a été refusé la saq a préféré
nous envoyer un courriel la société des
alcools du québec suit ce dossier depuis
plusieurs mois
dès que nous avons été informés qu'il
était possible que nos produits fassent
l'objet de contrebande réponse
surprenante puisque tous ceux à qui nous
avons parlé au cours de notre enquête
ont affirmé que la saq est au courant de
ce problème et puis plusieurs amis se
souhaiter ça c'est sûr ceux ci ont été
sensibilisés eu des rencontres dans le
passé avec doivent poser la question
pourquoi que la succursale de dorval
on a besoin d'eux ils savent que c'est
pour faire du trafic
ils savent que c'est illégal que c'est
pour revendre
la société d'état nous dit qu'après
avoir pris connaissance du problème
elle a contacté rapidement la sûreté du
québec la saq nous confirme et ajoute
que le dossier est actif les policiers
du nunavik montre aussi du doigt les
compagnies aériennes qui sont l'une des
principales voies d'entrée de l'alcool
de contrebande
déjà qu'ils remontent ce bar leurs
bagages ou même par 4 go c'est faux
c'est aucun aucun screen and security
effet le ca dre beaucoup s'il y en avait
[Musique]
sans grande surprise les bouteilles que
nous avons envoyé sont toutes arrivées à
destination
forcé et air inuit sont la propriété de
la société makivik makivik protège les
droits et intérêts des inuits et gère
entre autres l'argent obtenu lors de la
signature de la convention de la baie
james et du nord québécois
nous avions beaucoup de questions à
poser à son président
charlie watts monsieur watch n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande d'entrevue
notre troisième boîte a été expédié par
postes canada qui interdit l'envoi
d'alcool elle est arrivée sans encombre
au bureau de poste de coo de joie qu où
l'attendaient notre collaborateur
c'est le courrier de la reine on ne peut
pas y toucher
la police ne peut rien faire sans un
inspecteur des postes et un inspecteur
des postes il n'y en a pas au nunavik
les enquêteurs de la police régionale
kativik aimerait pouvoir ouvrir
eux-mêmes les colis postes canada a elle
aussi décliné notre demande d'entrevue
elle a préféré nous envoyer un courriel
ou elle mentionne qu'elle fait ce qu'il
faut pour intercepter les envois
d'alcool et qu'elle collabore avec la
police
elle préfère ne rien révéler sur les
nouvelles mesures de sécurité mises en
place il ya maintenant pour ne pas nuire
à leur efficacité pour l'enquêteur
johnson postes canada pour en faire
davantage
il faudrait faire plus d'interventions
chez postes canada pour empêcher
l'alcool d'entrée sur le territoire
postes canada est une voie d'accès
importante mais on fait une opération
tous les trois mois si on est chanceux
une autre manière de s'attaquer à la
contrebande
c'est d'offrir des services pour ceux
qui souffre d'alcoolisme
ces services sont déficients il n'y a
qu'une seule organisation qui traite les
dépendances ou nunavik
c'est le centre histoire civique à coude
jacques qui peine à répondre à la
demande
un nouveau centre construit au coût de
40 25 millions de dollars ouvrira ses
portes fin 2021
c'est alicia aragou taxe est ancien
client des bootleggers qui dirige
histoire civique
un look et la femme les programmes au
yukon gold the process nationale
[Musique]
il y a huit ans béatrice d eux a dû
quitter son village pour traiter sa
dépendance à l'alcool et au bout des
gants j'avais des problèmes de colère
j'avais des des pensées suicidaires
et il n'y avait pas de live à roanne
quand je vais vers rome c'est à montréal
à près de 1800 kilomètres de son village
que béatrice a reçu toute l'aide dont
elle avait besoin problème c'est qu'elle
le gouvernement amène pas des ressources
dans nos régions
on ne reçoivent pas les mêmes services
quelques taux canadien cet artiste
engagé multiplie les tribunes elle donne
ici un spectacle pour venir en aide aux
femmes autochtones itinérantes de
montréal
béatrice dire est loin d'avoir dit son
dernier mot
[Musique]
nyatto le camp de l'espoir
c'est la seule chose qu'on peut faire
qu'on peut avoir c'est de l'espoir c'est
trop tôt car tout le monde est mal mais
on est encore vivants
quand on est vivants y apporter de
l'espoir à la suite de notre reportage
on est retourné sur le terrain pour voir
si les choses ont changé et vous allez
voir que ça fait pas mal réagir
notamment la saq
[Musique]
nous sommes retournés voir béatrice dire
cette fois ci dans la région de montréal
où elle réside
elle a reçu peu de commentaires négatifs
à la suite de son intervention
bien au contraire beaucoup de sport
beaucoup de gens qui ont apprécié que le
problème était exposé c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau mais il ya des yeux
nouveaux qui sont ceux qui on veut ce
problème là parmi ces nouveaux entre
autres ceux d'un acteur important du
ministre des finances eric girard
responsable de la saq
ce qu'il a fait surtout réagir ce sont
les ravages causés par l'alcool à 94%
j'en ai pris congé en ciel est si
sérieux et je peux annoncer dès
maintenant que pour ce qui est de
l'alcool à 94
ça va être facile et des tables aussitôt
dit aussitôt fait nous avons constaté
qu'on l'emmenait de la diffusion de
notre reportage
il n'était plus possible de trouver de
l'alcool à 94% sur les étagères de la
saq
nous avons tourné ces images en caméra
cachée ou obss j'en ai pu y en a pu vous
regardez dans le système et david 7
c'est la 7e au courant pour l'alcool 94
s'est rendu en arrière s'est rendu à
l'arrière ok c'est sur demande
c'est sur demande seulement
l'instruction qu'on a ce de les retirer
des tablettes mais de les garder en
arrière pour beaucoup plus voir qu'on a
nos cliniques on peut en acheter plein
pourquoi donc à cause de reportage d'
enquête sur la consommation d'alcool
dans le nord et le trafic d'alcool entre
le sud et nord apparemment ça fait
partie du problème
il est donc encore très facile de s'en
procurer
nous avons répété l'expérience cette
fois ci en demandant l'aide
collaborateurs d'origine inuit
vous en voulez une quasi au complet
oui dans voudrait combien se dit capable
d'en produire 15 caisses de 24
oui pour garder comme les gens lisent
j'aimerais juste douze visites sinon
j'ai des 1.14 litres il n'y aura pas de
problème si je ramène ça dans le grand
nord la décision de retirer cet alcool
puissant des tablettes a tout de même eu
un effet dissuasif dans le petit village
d'à coups livic il a été à l'origine de
bien des tragédies
la mairesse suppléante mais oui à la
cool ya look l'a constaté on l'avait oui
et l'ont arrêté
je pense que ça que le bape le bayer
plus sur les tablettes mais ils ont
derrière ils l'ont dahlback store vous
avez vu une différence
oui à plus tard la commune en caisse
le directeur des opérations du corps de
police régionale kativik jean françois
morin nous confirment qu'il n'y aurait
plus d'alcool à 94% sur le territoire du
nunavik avez vous vu une différence sur
le fait est qu'ils ont de plus au début
de la pandémie en pleine pénurie de
désinfectant la saq a fait don de tous
son inventaire soit 1500 bouteilles à la
santé publique pour pallier au manque de
produits antiseptiques
aujourd'hui cet alcool controversé est
de retour dans les succursales de la
société d'état mais toujours sur demande
quelques jours après la diffusion de
notre reportage
la sûreté du québec et le corps de
police kativik ont mené l'opération
plutonium
revenu québec postes canada et la saq
ont collaboré à l'enquêté
les perquisitions ont eu lieu dans la
région de montréal et dans cinq villages
du nunavik dans leur mire cinq personnes
qui contrôlerait jusqu'à 70% de l'alcool
de contrebande ou nunavik
les suspects auraient acheté depuis 2016
près de trente neuf mille bouteilles
d'alcool fort surtout de la vodka qu'il
revendrait 12 soit le prix
les policiers ont également saisi des
drogues dures des teaser des voitures
l'enquêté toujours en cours
cette vaste opération a ébranlé le
milieu un homme est allé me voir dans un
magasin quand j'étais au noir [ __ ]
était vraiment content de me dire que il
ya des blogueurs qui sont un peu énervés
maintenant devant
au début de la pandémie les autorités de
nunavik prennent la décision de
restreindre les quantités de bière et de
vin et d'interdire l'achat en ligne de
votre cas on veut limiter les dérives
résultat une baisse impressionnante du
nombre de délits reliés à l'alcool
sa variante et de réglages à l'officier
ou une toque lost et 90% moins
d'interventions l'espace internautes et
leurs bambins mais l'arrêt complet de la
cua ce seul village où il y en avait
complet pas mal de rythme dans les
autres villages pour ces données qui
sont considérables mais l'accalmie a été
de courte durée
la rareté de l'alcool a contribué à
créer de nouveaux réseaux de
contrebandiers l'opération plutonium n'a
pas eu l'effet escompté dans ces
perquisitions alors pas donné grand
chose là c'est un tabou sur le coup mais
sans plus on est conscients des softs et
leur honneur on ne démarre à lire un
gros réseau mais c'est pas long qui en
est donc fonctionnement la police a
effectué depuis d'autres saisies ou
nunavik les bootleggers envoie la
marchandise surtout par la poste
une source confidentielle du travail
dans un aéroport du nunavik nous
confirme c'est le reportage
il ya eu une baisse après le reportage
puis ça recommence et c'est fou c'est
fou tout ce qui monte par la poste
toute la boisson qui monte par la poste
pendant la pandémie ça continue d'entrer
ouais pareil ça peut changer c'est
sudoku khalid al toual qui en sait sur
un volume chronique colis généraux qui
rend tous ses repères c'est pour ces
cinq personnages regardent
nous saluons cet alcool c'est des
milliers des milliers de brochures
anthony navettes quotidiennes mal les
choses quand on reçoit un peu depuis la
pandémie et ne voit pas beaucoup de
cargos mais c'est par la poste canada
que les personnes le soir de la cour on
a besoin d'un gouvernement du canada
parce que c'est que sans un jardin cas
n'est pas parce que les médias ont eu
plusieurs discussions avec canada.ca
gemeaux compères avec nous l'on se rend
compte que deux succès organisme qui
envoie en grande quantité trouve des
comptoirs où c'est peut-être moins
surveillées partie ils trouvent des
dimensions plus faible dans la chaîne
non d'actes et sur ce qu'on travaille
la police régionale kativik n'a pas dit
son dernier mot
elle vient de mettre sur pied une
escouade spéciale pour contrer la
contrebande
quatre nouveaux patrouilleurs et deux
autres enquêteurs travailleront en
étroite collaboration avec la sûreté du
québec
du côté du gouvernement régional
nous avons voulu connaître sa position
sur la contrebande et les solutions
envisagées pour venir à bout de ce
problème récurrent à deux reprises et à
la dernière minute
la présidente de l'administration
régionale kativik
jennyfer music annuler notre rendez vous
et cela sans donner aucune explication
concept les leaders ou navic ne pas aux
efforts contre la contrebande est ce que
c'est une idée que je veux c'est où
c'est vraiment le cas y en at il
on y en a qui bossent sur wii c'est
complexe pierre on n'a pas trouvé la
bonne formule encore lors du dernier
conseil régional qui regroupe tous les
maires des villages
le chef de police du nunavik jean pierre
larose avait lancé l'idée de permettre
la vente locale de bière dans les
villages sec
c'est sûr que de contrôler salut des
effets négatifs et sa soeur incite les
gens la contrebande faction contrôlions
bali complètement dont manquerait que la
contrebande prendrai vraiment le dessus
chaque village à une réalité qui lui est
propre difficile de faire l'unanimité
sur la vente ou non d'alcool en raison
de la pandémie la construction de
nouveaux centres et soir civique pour
traiter les problèmes de dépendance est
retardée pour l'instant en juin dernier
les autorités ont permis à nouveau
l'achat en ligne de vodka ou autres
alcools forts la décision de lever les
restrictions fait partie des mesures de
déconfinement est de retour à la vie
normale
ce reportage que vous venez de voir il
ya quelque chose de spécial parce que
c'est le dernier reportage signée josée
dupuis
notre collègue qui vient de prendre sa
retraite après la pause on va revenir
sur le parcours de cette journaliste
exceptionnel
[Musique]
on pouvait pas vous présenter ce
reportage sans revenir sur la carrière
exceptionnelle de notre collègue josée
dupuis qui est parti à la retraite
josé c'est une journaliste qui a marqué
l'enquète au québec qui a gagné des prix
au canada mais aussi partout dans le
monde et probablement que l'un ou
l'autre de ces reportages vous a
bouleversé
[Applaudissements]
à force de rester enfermé cette chaîne
tourne en rond continuellement la loi
actuelle ne peut rien pour elle au
canada gardez un chien en cage toute sa
vie n'est pas un acte de cruauté
[Musique]
il ya peu de canadiens qui accepteraient
que leur gouvernement wallon de la mort
comprenez vous sur les marchés c'est du
chat après l'éjection du barbituriques
réussissent à s'enfuir de leur cage
le chat gris rampe sur le plancher des
pattes arrières paralysé il va mourir
tout près de la cage de ce chien sous le
regard indifférent des employés
[Musique]
et wassim daou services tiennent à
tomber à master avec un répit nos coeurs
[Musique]
à 14 ans qui concerne ici ttc ma
cachette
[Musique]
arnèke à 16 ans maintenant les images du
drame
comme toujours il souffre du syndrome du
survivant comme chez certains garçons de
polytechnique
il aurait voulu arrêter le tueur enfin
alors je pense que c'est ce qui permet à
[Musique]
ces femmes pour la première fois
prennent la parole et dénonce
publiquement le mépris qu'ils subissent
de la part de ceux qui normalement
devrait les protéger
je ressors je suis pas pour mais les
filles ou même une petite fille je suis
cramé moi aujourd'hui c'est 900 vols ou
pas
c'est comme ça que se terminent les
missions cette semaine au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
et je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
on
[Musique]